como si fuesen dos realidades paralelas
por un lado los delegados electorales
votando por otro escasos seguidores de
trans manifestándose y mientras joe
biden superó el penúltimo obstáculo
antes de convertirse oficialmente en
presidente del colegio electoral declaró
la victoria del demócrata tras recibir
el apoyo de california un triunfo que
celebro reivindicando el papel de las
instituciones
elmer faucett en eeuu los políticos no
toman el poder el pueblo les da a ellos
el poder la llama de la democracia se
encendió en este país hace mucho tiempo
y ahora sabemos que nada ni siquiera una
pandemia un abuso de poder pueden
extinguir esa llama de wish that wave en
eeuu el presidente no se define por voto
popular sino por los delegados de los
colegios electorales de 50 estados y el
distrito de columbia un trámite
históricamente simbólico que ante las
acusaciones de fraude de donald trump ha
ganado fuerza en estos comicios pero las
derrotas legales del republicano dejaban
poco margen para imaginar que los
representantes fuesen a desobedecer
entonces si el colegio electoral elige
como presidente a joe biden no
abandonará la casa blanca
mira está claro que lo haré lo haré y lo
sabes jonathan a pesar de esta
afirmación todo indica que antes del 6
de enero trump todavía presentará
mociones con remotas probabilidades de
que prosperen entonces ese día será la
fecha en la que habrá una sesión
conjunta entre el senado y la cámara de
representantes un momento definitivo en
el que el vicepresidente mike pence
tendrá que declarar como ganadora baiden
para que después el 20 de enero tome
posesión junto a camada harris